y cuba sufre un pico pandémico por la
variante delta con un incremento de
miles de casos diarios desde semanas a
pesar de contar con un plan de
vacunación que ya inmunizó a más del 60%
de la población y dos vacunas producidas
localmente soberana y abdalá el sistema
de salud cubano se encuentra sobrepasado
tenemos bastante fallecido la
institución y que tenemos una sola
morgue que tenemos un solo crematorio y
que son muchos fallecidos el presidente
de cuba miguel díaz-canel mencionó los
esfuerzos que se realizan para enfrentar
la pandemia y pidió hacer un esfuerzo a
la población les pido comprensión
compromiso y pensamiento sobre todo para
en el menor tiempo posible estar en las
condiciones para sobrepasar este pico
pandémico que podemos vencer señal de la
agudeza de la situación cientos de
doctores cubanos que se encontraban en
misiones en diferentes países regresaron
a la isla para brindar apoyo en
hospitales si bien cuba mantuvo los
casos de kobe bajo control durante el
primer año de la pandemia la variante
delta cambió esta situación
los casos que surgen a partir de la de
la cepa delta que es una cepa más
expansiva de una cepa más
agresiva indiscutiblemente que nos está
creando situaciones complejas a nivel de
a nivel hospitalario
también desde el extranjero llegan
medicamentos para aliviar la escasez de
productos de salud muestra de la
solidaridad de la diáspora cubana el
gobierno cubano que enfrenta el pico
pandémico con un embargo de eeuu y en
temporada de huracanes llamó al personal
de salud acelerar los procesos de
vacunación suministros de oxígeno y
medicamentos